christmas has come and gone
unfortunately the presents are all open
now it's time for the cleanup the
alcoholman shares how to properly
dispose of all the paper
boxes and the tree tis the season to
recycle your christmas tree
before you do there's some things to
remember before dropping off your tree
remove all the lights
wire tinsel ornaments and nails the
trees are turned into mulch which is
used at city parks
so any foreign objects can contaminate
the mulch and ruin the chipper flock
trees the ones with artificial snow
cannot be recycled
last year nearly 17 thousand trees were
recycled and when it comes to tossing
out gift boxes and festive paper
not everything is on the nice list a
paper fiber can be recycled seven to 12
times the reds and the greens are not
very recyclable friendly
so when we say those type of wrapping
papers when in doubt throw it out
recycling managers say the red and
greens cannot be dyed
so it's a problem when companies want to
turn it into a new paper product some
other things on the naughty list are
tissue paper
gift tags and tree lights reporting
bianca holman
8 news now